the other thing that's happening right
is that animals are getting bigger yeah
because they're and also their niche is
getting bigger
well this is the just sorry to take a
tiny tangent on the niche thing
is uh it seems like the niche is getting
bigger but not just bigger
like more complicated like shaped in
weird ways so like predation seems to
create
like like the whole world becomes your
oyster whatever
but like you also start to carve out
like the places in which you can operate
the best
yeah and in fact that's absolutely right
and in fact
some scientists think that theory of
mind
your ability to make inferences about
the in inner life of
of other creatures actually developed
under the selection pressure of
predation
because it makes you a better predator
do you ever look at
you just said you looked at babies as
these wiring creatures do you ever think
of
humans as just clever predators
like that there is under uh underneath
it all is this
uh the nietzschean will the power
in all of its forms or are we now
friendlier yeah so it's interesting
i mean there there there are zeitgeists
in how
humans think about themselves right and
so if you look in the
20th century you can see that
the idea of an inner beast that we're
just predators we're just basically
animals
baseless animals violent animals that
have to be contained
by culture and by our prodigious
neocortex
really took hold
particularly after world war one
and really um
held sway for much of that century um
and then around at least in western
writing i would say you know we're we're
talking mainly about western
western scientific writing western
philosophical writing
and and then you know late 90s maybe
um you start to see books and articles
about
our social nature that we're social
animals and we are social animals but
what does that mean
exactly and um
about it's just carving out different
niches in the space of ideas it looks
like i think so
i think so so um so
you know do um humans
um are can humans be violent yes
can can humans be really helpful
yes actually and humans are
interesting creatures because you know
other animals can also be helpful to one
another in fact there's a whole
literature
booming literature on how other animals
um are um
you know support one another they they
regulate each other's nervous systems in
in interesting ways and they will be
helpful to one another right so for
example there's a whole literature on
rodents and how um they um
they signal one another what what is
safe to eat and
uh they will perform
uh acts of generosity
to their con specifics that are related
to them
or or who they were raised with so if an
animal was raised in a litter
that is that they were raised in
although not even at the same time
they'll be more likely to help that
animal
so there's always some kind of physical
relationship between
animals that predicts whether or not
they'll help one another
for humans
humans you know we have ways of
categorizing who's in our who's in our
group and who isn't
by non-physical ways right by even by
just something abstract like an idea
and we are much more likely to extend
help to people in our own group whatever
that group may be
um at that moment whatever your whatever
feature you're using to define who's in
your group and who isn't
um we're more likely to help those
people than even
members of our own family at times so
humans are much more flexible in their
in the way that they help one another
but also in the way that they harm one
another so i don't
um i don't i don't think i subscribe to
um you know we are
primarily this or we are primarily that
i don't think have humans have essences
in that way
really
you